I've gotten used to them the feet you
never think about how many feet they
have how they grip it your skin and the
hair on your body how they hold on to
you so effortlessly
they almost tickle almost the smell
that's barely noticeable anymore
at first it was it was pretty bad I
threw up a lot and they started crawling
into my mouth when I was trying to eat
but then I realized they didn't mind
when I ate them I think that was when I
started to come to terms with it they
didn't taste good at first but then the
crunch insects have a texture all in
their own thick and sweet and full of I
don't know what but it was the best
thing I've ever eaten and they didn't
even mind there was so much I could just
reach out and take I think they'd like
to see me to sleep it's hard to ignore
it when they're in my ears well
everywhere else too
all kinds of things chirping and buzzing
around all the time constant noise I
mean it's a lot louder than the summer a
lot louder I don't think I mind though
that they just like to sing it's almost
like music I can see them watching me
not the crawling things No
the people I know how you see me even in
the places where the strange people live
people who the world forgot even they
look away I can see it in their eyes
they pity me or they're just plain
grossed out revolted you two I see
you've tried to look me in the eye not
at the bits of my hair and not of my
teeth I've seen that look before
you don't want to you can't help but
stare I know you can't they never can
I gave up trying to wash them off not in
a shower or a bathtub those aren't big
enough not enough water to wash them
away not that I didn't try it's just a
lost cause at that scale I mean I still
have scars from scrubbing so hard then I
started to go swimming to drown them
like the story of the Pied Piper you
know he took the rats away and drown
them in the river I always loved
swimming even before it gave me that
little breath of cleanness and then then
the leeches found me
leeches aren't ants are the worst
they're so small they get all over my
hair and my nose my ears in my eyes
thousands of them it's it's just I can't
do I can't even describe it just imagine
every inch of your body cover never mind
I'm sorry I'm sorry I never mentioned
the rats always so many but I guess
they're not at least they're warm
there's so many
they keep me warm in the cold like a
fuzzy blanket a fuzzy hungry blanket
people keep rats as pets right it's no
different and everyone loves pets I love
my pets I love them all
I'll never be alone